[Musica]
quando scritto per la prima volta questo
talk all'inizio di quest'anno da
archeologo avrei voluto parlarvi del
patrimonio culturale mondiale
un patrimonio che noi riteniamo sicuro
lì fisso pronto ad attenderci che invece
purtroppo è costantemente sotto pericolo
io avrei fatto qualche esempio
abbastanza forte ricordandovi dei
conflitti per esempio in siria in iraq
le distruzioni di siti archeologici come
palmira ninive molti altri di aver
ricordato dell'incendio il 2018 del
museo nazionale di rio de janeiro il più
grande museo del sud america
per quanto riguarda l'archeologia
devastato dalle fiamme in poche ore
infine sicuramente perso un po tutti
andando nemmeno troppo in là con la
memoria si pensi solo nel 2019 che avrei
riportato alla mente l'incendio di notre
dame
penso che più o meno penso che più o
meno tutti abbiamo seguito questo evento
in televisione se in diretta oppure
tramite social bene quando poi ripreso
questo talk subito dopo il lock down
mi è sembrato doveroso fare un focus
invece sull'italia perché la chiusura
prolungata dei musei il blocco in
entrata e uscita delle nostre mostre ma
soprattutto la mancanza del turismo di
massa che per anni ha trainato le nostre
città d'arte e cosa intendo con turismo
di massa intendo milioni i turisti
provenienti dall'asia dall'america che
quest'anno non sono venuti ha messo in
ginocchio il nostro sistema culturale e
che cosa intendo con sistema culturale
intendo tutti quegli operatori si pensi
a società cooperative ma anche singoli
professionisti che operano nei musei
siti archeologici nel nostro turismo e
che quest'anno non hanno lavorato
io ritengo che sia ancora possibile
ovviamente dare una mano al nostro al
nostro sistema culturale perché se
collassa e sistema culturale con l'asta
anche il nostro patrimonio culturale
perché sono le persone che sono addette
alla fruizione di questo patrimonio
ma in parte anche alla protezione quindi
sono qui per dare qualche consiglio
diciamo che ci sono due vie una
sicuramente più civica che puoi fare tu
possiamo fare noi
e poi una più professionale per quanto
riguarda diciamo questa via civica
in realtà a ho rischiato per la quarta o
quinta volta il talk verso fine
dell'estate anche un po gasato col fatto
che si potesse viaggiare potesse vedere
volevo oggi avrei voluto dirvi viaggiato
e fate questo fate quell'altro oggi
sarebbe da irresponsabili purtroppo
quindi vi dico di dare anche una piccola
mano magari alle realtà del paese della
città dove voi vivete aiutato in un
museo un sito archeologico
come potete fare io ho pensato e ho
buttato lì un'idea
pensando al caffè sospeso scommettete
sul fatto di poter andare entrare entro
un museo comprato un biglietto magari
poi non andate però serve a dare
sicuramente un aiuto a questa realtà
queste piccole realtà che però fanno
parte di tutto un grande sistema che il
nostro patrimonio culturale
vi dico anche di più si può dare anche
una mano magari da casa andando sui siti
internet dei musei informandoci
guardando anche dei video
devo dire che in questo momento ci sono
giovani informatori culturali
professionisti
mi viene in mente per farvi un esempio
le passeggiate del direttore sono dei
video di 10 minuti che farà il direttore
museo egizio e torino in cui spiega
alcune particolarità della civiltà
egizia facendo questa meravigliosa
passeggiata all'interno delle sale è un
modo per creare visibilità
per dire noi ci siamo ci sono tantissimi
video io gli dico così poi ognuno deve
seguire anche la sua passione ci sono
video fatti coi droni che sorvolano i
nostri siti archeologici nostre città
vuote
adesso vi posso dire che cosa stiamo
cercando di fare noi professionisti io
sono un archeologo come vi ho detto con
professionisti in realtà
intendiamo tantissimi tipologie di
operatori restauratori archeologi
curatori custodi guide e tanti altri io
dal canto mio mi son chiesto che cosa
deve fare l'archeologo nel 2020 e quindi
ho voluto creare un sistema
tecnologicamente avanzato per il
monitoraggio dei beni culturali
il progetto si chiama e rari un chain e
unisce due parole erario dal latino
erario e che quindi il tesoro dello
stato romano le antichità e c'è in
riprendendo il nome ovviamente di una
tecnologia che utilizziamo che vuol dire
catena in inglese per noi ovviamente
questo erario e il patrimonio contenuta
all'interno dei musei come funziona
questo sistema
ho voluto col mio team creare prenderle
tecnologie migliori che ci sono al
momento quindi sono tre tecnologie che
utilizziamo sono l'immagine 3d quindi
dalla scansione 3d opera d'arte fatta in
periodi diversi di tempo quindi dal
giorno zero ogni sei mesi un anno viene
fatta una scansione diversa viene
caricata sul nostro sistema che nota
riza diciamo questo momento creando la
block chain successivamente
l'intelligenza artificiale compara
queste immagini 3d e permette di dire se
ci sono delle modificazioni non visibili
a occhio nudo per intervenire sull'opera
prontamente poi adesso vi guarderete
direte beh certo aspetti sei mesi un
anno ma in realtà per opere che sono
ferme da 100 1000 anni
anche questo arco di tempo di pochi mesi
o anni è fondamentale
in realtà siamo tanti operatori che ci
stiamo reinventando nelle tecnologie o
colleghi per esempio che stanno
lavorando per creare percorsi tattili
all'interno dei musei per gli ipovedenti
e come si fa si prende le immagini 3d
dell'opera d'arte viene stampata e si dà
la possibilità di toccare la copia è
come toccare l'opera d'arte vera ci sono
colleghi che stanno ricostruendo il
patrimonio andato distrutto durante la
guerra in siria la guerra in iraq e vi
viene in mente il project mosul
a volte la ricostruzione parte dalle
fotografie sia professionali ma anche
fatte dai turisti e quindi utilizzando
la fotogrammetria che una tecnologia in
cui unendo fotografie fatte intorno a un
oggetto tramite internati software può
creare un modello 3d e stiamo
ricostruendo quindi questo patrimonio in
parte che è andato perduto
devo dire che noi operatori
io metto questa categoria insieme a
tutti i miei colleghi
stiamo facendo in modo di continuare a
proteggere ea rendere fruibile questo
patrimonio
ma non può partire solo da noi dobbiamo
prenderci cura del nostro patrimonio
come comunità tutti insieme e dobbiamo
farci conquistare da questa bellezza che
in ogni angolo del nostro paese dal
piccolo paesino alla grande città
quindi vi chiedo di sostenere il nostro
patrimonio
[Applauso]